hi everyone i'm sam copeland i'm a
national master on the content team here
at chess.com
and i'm here today to show you an
immortal game won by stockfish new in
the king's indian defense
now we've been looking at some brilliant
games by stockfish new on this channel
some have claimed that the stockfish new
engine is the new strongest chess engine
on the planet
we tested that in a tournament with lila
chess zero
stockfish new and traditional stock fish
ultimately leela chest zero was
victorious in a very close competition
however stockfish newt so impressed the
team behind stockfish
that they are merging stockfish new into
the traditional stockfish program
stockfish new uses a neural network in
place of the traditional evaluation
function
it's very likely that the next version
of stockfish that you install on your
computer
will support neural networks in this
game we see leela chess zero playing
white
and stockfish new plays black i truly
think that the victory by stockfish new
here is the finest king's indian defense
victory that i've ever seen
the king's indian defense is of course
highly theoretical
in this game the engines are going to
follow theory for 14 moves before
they start thinking on their own that's
actually by design as we program the
engines in the computer chess
championship to play
very interesting and specific positions
we want something complex we don't want
berlin defenses
here we're going to see the classic mar
del plata variation that is defined by
the move
knight to e1 in this position this is
one of the sharpest king's indian
defense variations which is of course
saying quite a lot white is going to be
pushing forward on the queen side
while black pushes forward on the king
side both players
must be committed relentlessly to the
attacks on the wings where they have the
advantage
here we have knight d7 bishop e3 pawn to
f5
f3 f4 bishop f2 onto g5
b4 knight f6 c5 knight g6
and the engines are finally thinking
totally on their own
from this position something that's
interesting about the king's indian
defense that i think makes it great for
computer
chess games is that almost all engines
really like the white side
of the game white has more space and
more obvious advantages
however you'll often see the evaluation
totally turn around in the king's indian
defense
as black's attack points at the white
king and at some point
the engines might realize that the white
king is actually in such grave danger
that there's no way to save it
here after knight g6 we see a4 h5
c6 king h8 sometimes in these kinds of
positions i don't know if a move is just
tremendously deep from the engine
or if it's actually slightly inaccurate
this has a point like rook g8
but as the game develops it's kind of
hard to believe that king h8 is
definitely the best move in the position
here we get a capture on b7 bishop takes
b7
king h1 note that this is primarily
defensive in nature whereas black's king
h8 is primarily aggressive in nature
and now bishop c8 knight to b5 pawn to
a6
knight to a7 this has the idea to maybe
put the knight on c6
and maybe exchange off the bishop on c8
depriving black of a critical attacker
here we get pawn to g4 knight take c8
and the very
interesting intermediate move on to g3
the knight on c8 isn't getting out so
you can leave it here while you push
forward and gain time for your attack
now a big question i have and maybe
someone with a stronger engine than me
might be able to answer this is why not
capture on g3 here and pick up a pawn
now black has some initiative here you
can capture on c8
or you could push forward right away
with pawn to h4
but i can't see that there's a clear win
or anything so my inclination is to take
this
certainly the way the game develops with
bishop g1
suggests that the pawn should probably
not be allowed to survive
on g3 if you can at all capture it and
get it off the board
so after bishop g1 we see queen takes c8
now b5
knight to h7 a5 white is pushing forward
trying to make a passer and a queen on
the queen side and black is pushing
forward
trying to make checkmate now you might
be inclined to play a move like h3 and
just say
i've totally blocked up the king side
you can't do anything else over there
and eventually i'll break through
on the queen side isn't white just
winning well
unfortunately basically always when you
play h3 in these positions
black will either sacrifice a bishop or
in this case a knight on
h3 the attack will break through black
will win the game
so after h4 this pawn must be allowed
forward
you get b6 you get pawn to h3
and now queen c2 knight g5 and in this
position
one question is why not capture up here
on c7
if queen takes c7 then h takes g2 knight
takes g2 and queen h3 is
really really strong black actually has
a huge threat here that i'm not going to
spoil
because it will come up later in the
game but if white defends against the
threat and plays a move like rook to c1
giving the king a little more breathing
room
black still wins with queen h5 here now
you're obviously putting pressure here
on this f3 pawn but what's actually
important
is if you play for example b7 which
looks really strong
knight to h3 this threatens knight takes
g1 and queen takes h2
or even more forcing after a capture on
h8 or a8 here
you have knight to f2 and bishop takes
and queen takes h2 mate
in fact there's no defense for white
here if in the position in the game the
queen had captured on c7
so in the game we actually see the move
rook to a2
from lila and then we get a capture on
g2 we get knight takes g2 and queen to
h3
now black is setting up that threat that
again i'm not spoiling just yet in this
position
the white needs to defend along the
second rank
white plays the very creative bishop
takes
a6 sacrificing a bishop
to get these past pawns going and also
this adds defense very critical defense
along the second rank
in fact could white just be winning by
force here
you get rook takes a6 and now pawn
forward
to b7 there's simply ideas like
capturing here
and then making a queen this rook goes
over to b8
and after queen takes c7 again it looks
like white is winning
in fact the low depth low depth stock
fish that i have here
in my browser is saying that white is
winning the opposite is true
black plays the brilliant move rook
takes b7
giving back immediately one rook in this
position and then
after queen takes b7 black follows up
again brilliantly
by giving up the other rook on a5
in this position you absolutely must
pause your video
and try to figure out why can white not
take the rook
on a5 the answer is that black has
a brilliant queen sacrifice to force
checkmate if the rook sacrifice is
accepted
rook takes a5 and then queen takes
g2 check after king takes we have knight
to h4
king back and then pawn to g2 and a
beautiful beautiful checkmate this is
the idea that has come up in many
previous variations
that i've been trying not to spoil until
this moment
lovers of classic kings indian defense
games will recognize this final
combination
from the famous game svetan vs tachnik i
will let better players than i correct
my pronunciation there
now of course the engine is not going to
allow this force checkmate
and after the rook sacrifice on a5 we
see rook to c2
then rook c5 and you can't capture again
because
of the mate we just saw with the queen
sacrifice or if the bishop captures then
there is made on h2 immediately
so we must play queen b2 or something
like it and now there's an exchange on
c2
k7 and this is a great position to pause
in
black is still down a complete exchange
how can black be better much less
winning
well the answer is in the question what
can white
move the answer is not much in fact
only the queen here the knight on g2
cannot move without the rook on f1
hanging
the bishop on g1 cannot move without
mate happening on h2
the rook cannot move without the f3 pawn
falling
again that leaves only the queen
so we see queen to e2 queen to h5
pulling back and attacking this pawn but
more importantly intending knight into
h3
and there then there are ideas like
knight takes g1 and mate down here on h2
so after queen h5 we see queen a6 knight
into h3
and then queen to b6 the queen must
defend this bishop so that if it is
captured the queen can pull back
and defend the mate now king h6
knight to e1 and here bishop f6
commencing a very nice bishop maneuver
queen b2
again the queen must defend either the
h2 square
or the bishop here to avoid these mating
ideas after exchanges on g1
bishop d8 a beautiful move
and now we have queen to a2 knight takes
g1
rook takes g1 and bishop to a5
it's interesting how black is down
material and still able to trade down
to get a winning combination here of
course you cannot capture this bishop
because of made on h2
so you cannot avoid here the elimination
of this knight
if the knight were to try to move for
example knight to d3 here then
f3 simply falls so
after bishop to a5 we have queen to b2
and now we trade on e1 rook takes and
this is winning
if you capture here right away but
sometimes the threat is stronger than
the execution
and knight to h4 before capturing on f3
f3 is falling and there's no way to save
this game
the rest is basically forced rookie 2
queen takes f3 check
king g1 queen to d3 ending many things
all of these look really really strong
and now captures on g3
queen captures on g3 check king over to
f1
and then queen h3 up check and then
we're going to get a night check that is
going to allow
this queen check and the rook is falling
also with check
then there's a queen trait and we're
going to simply queen the uh
f pawn now humans would resign but in
the computer chess championship we have
the engines play on to mate the final
moves always happen very very quickly
and the queen and knight don't need much
to fit to finish off here with checkmate
on b5 i hope that you've enjoyed this
game
i enjoyed it tremendously i truly do
think it is the finest kings indian
defense game i've ever seen
if you disagree and have another king's
indian defense game that you love more
or just that you also love and want to
share please include it in the comments
below
if you want to see more stockfish new
games then simply click on the videos
that are sitting right on top of your
screen